[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal einen
gemüseauflauf wirklich ist was ganz
klassisches was schnell geht was man bis
in den ofen schiebt und wofür man
einfach nicht zehn jahre überlegen muss
was koche ich heute heute komplett ohne
fleisch und ich fange jetzt auch direkt
an die ganzen mengenangabe schreibe ich
euch wie immer unten in die infobox und
ich nehme heute die drei klassiker für
mich ist es halt wirklich immer
blumenkohl brokkoli und kartoffeln ihr
könntet auch möhren dazu geben oder ich
habe mir einfach was für euch in seinen
klassischen gemüseauflauf rein muss ich
habe es gerne jetzt in die kommentare
weil wenn ich hier so lese dann fange
ich schon andere inspiration zu sammeln
fürs nächste video wichtig ist dass wir
das alles schön fein säubern also
wirklich unter fließendem wasser waschen
und jetzt blumenkohl und brokkoli in
feine röllchen schneiden und die
kartoffeln wenn ich gleich schälen und
entweder hobelt ihr sie fein oder ihr
schneidet sie in ganz feine scheiben
denn heute wird nichts vorgekocht
[Musik]
das gemüse habe ich jetzt direkt in
meiner auflaufform gegeben ihr könnt
eure auch schon vom auch noch fett wenn
ihr euch unsicher seid oder wenn ihr
denkt lebt noch immer was dran bei mir
geht das eigentlich immer ganz gut klar
ich nehme jetzt als basis sahne und
milch einfach damit nicht ganz so fertig
ist einfach zusammen in eine große
schüssel geben und dann hab ich immer so
zwei optionen die ich gerne mache
entweder nehme ich jetzt einfach nur auf
die schnelle mein café de paris gewürzes
ist eine kräuter gewürzmischung als auch
schon knoblauch petersilie der täterin
einfach geil nehmen verrühren und
dazugeben falls ihr die nicht daheim
habt habe ich für euch eine andere
alternative und zwar nehme ich daher
gemüsebrühe frischen knoblauch
paprikapulver edelsüß und salz und
pfeffer
[Musik]
so ich hab jetzt die soße komplett
einmal darüber gegeben und ich möchte es
folgendermaßen ich nehme mir jetzt
alufolie und jetzt einmal verschließen
das hat den einfachen grund dass auch
wirklich alles gut und nachher werden
das natürlich überbacken was für ein
auflauf wenn jetzt nicht mehr packen
wäre also ich gebe dann gleich nach 45
minuten bei 200 grad ober unterhitze den
käse darüber entfernt natürlich
natürlich die folie und wird dann noch
mal so goldbraun backen das dauert dann
im anschluss nochmals 20 bis 25 minuten
und dann ist er auch schon fertig der
auflauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir machen jetzt den testlauf von meinem
gemüse auf den gast kind bei mir immer
ganz auf durch auch sehr oft sogar sehr
sehr um immer so blumenkohl broccoli
kartoffeln mein name ist gesund sein
schlagzeug herrsche große gefahren oder
hat vielleicht auch gut so
denkt sich eigentlich aber das
ganz genau ich hasse es wirklich hasse
es wenn also ich bin doch dank aber ich
hasse es wenn ich einen zu kleinen
teller bekommen bei michaels amerika
bereits nach links aber dafür hast du
doch so ein tablett du weißt doch nicht
ich mag das nicht ja das hast du damit
und sagt jetzt hier
nicht beschweren lokation auf höchsten
also handelt dann einen teller wollte
immer
schon als du das ist ich das natürlich
doch
also ohne witz man kriegt mich immer in
ihrem dunkel war es direkt durch
geflutscht das ist ja schön leicht das
ist ein klassischer
klassischer ablauf und der geht immer
und immer und stoppt den eben auch
kinder finde ich gut lecker lecker so
ich würde mal sagen wir wünschen euch
viel spaß im nachnamen haben sie doch
mal was zu sagen
mein teller geht damit zum esstisch und
gestern zu ende geht macht wohnt ergeben
du bist mal die hälfte
denn wir sehen
[Musik]